et pour ce qui est contre la science et
le vite
la séance est levée passé on se devait
placer un bon jour andré chassaigne
député du puy-de-dôme
mais aujourd'hui je me suis dit confiné
pour aller dans une autre
circonscription en limite de ma
circonscription pour rencontrer les
salariés de l'entreprise dux faire et
leurs organisations syndicales pour que
ce formidable outil de travail puisse
reprendre son activité dans l'intérêt de
notre pays
ce formidable outil de travail comme dit
andré chassaigne se situe près de
clermont ferrand
c'est une usine à l'arrêt depuis un an
et qui aujourd'hui est au coeur des
préoccupations de trois députés de la
région depuis la crise du comique 19
andré chassaigne le député communiste et
les anciens salariés sont persuadés
qu'elle doit rouvrir de toute urgence
car elle fabriquait des produits au
combien d'actualité
la crise du commis de 19 ans noah nos
bouteilles partout mais ça me fout la
mort on est chez nous on est chez nous
on est bloqué alors on allait occuper
l'usiné pendant 53 jours ont regardé les
infos envoyez là on voyait tout nos
bouteilles passé en disant qu'ils
étaient en saturation
c'était l'italie qui n'arrivait pas à
terre les bouteilles et nous on est à
l'arrêt et on nous empêche de démarrer
en pleine crise sanitaire ans pourra
venir bosser et traille l'intérêt public
et aider à sauver des vies et s'assoit
pour les pompiers ou les hôpitaux et on
reste soudé qu au regard des magrets
fermé parce que on nous empêche de
redémarrer légion chez lux faire on
fabriquait des bouteilles d'oxygène
utilisé par les ambulanciers pour
transférer des patients en insuffisance
respiratoire
cette usine était d'ailleurs la dernière
de l'union européenne à produire ses
réservoirs en aluminium léger et ultra
résistant durant des mois les salariés
se sont battus pour maintenir la
production
assemblée générale occupation de
l'entreprise manifestation ils ont même
trouvé un repreneur
en vain la direction anglo-américaine
transfert lusine du puy de dôme en
angleterre ne voulant pas d'un
concurrent sur le sol européen
mais les machines intransportable sont
toujours là et les salariés sont
disponibles
combien de temps plein voilà on pourrait
redémarrer en 9 semaines et est
dérogatoire qui en ce moment pour un
géré pendant pendant la crise après six
semaines pour produire pour produire
aujourd'hui pour sortir la première
aujourd'hui les bouteilles d'oxygène
s'avèrent des produits essentiels dans
le traitement du coronavirus quand tu es
en cas de pandémie comme on a eu
aujourd'hui quand on ouvre des salles
supplémentaires dans son hôpital lasalle
les salles supplémentaires qui sont
ouvertes elles sont pas alimentés par le
système général au niveau d'oxygène donc
il faut bien des bouteilles
pour eux il n'y a pas de doute les
bouteilles luxfer sont des produits
stratégiques pour l'indépendance
sanitaires de notre pays et pour nous
montrer que ces bouteilles font partie
du b à ba du matériel de secours
même hors épidémie le député n'a
d'ailleurs pas à aller très loin
comme partout en france les pompiers de
son petit village en sont équipés
d'abord pour se protéger remettre
des bouteilles nous sert pour les
interventions incendie pour protéger les
personnels lors des interventions sur
incendie mais également sur les coûts
d'intervention dans un bâtiment dont on
admire vicié et des bouteilles sur
plusieurs années a cédé recharge en fait
c'est des bouteilles qui sont éprouvés
tous les quarante mois m'ont enlevé
preuve le prestataire de service
définies si la bouteille peut être
remise en service ou pas si elle peut
être mise en service elle repart pour
quarante mans
au bout de 40 mois il revient mais c'est
la même qui revient vers vous ada court
donc les recharger
et ça s'éduque c'est aussi en moyenne
une bouteille doit être changée tous les
7 à 10 ans d'autres bouteilles luxe
faire servent elles aux patients en cas
de problèmes respiratoires ou d'arrêt
cardiaque
donc c'est des bouteilles qui nous
servent pour toutes les interventions
secours à personne avec ça on peut
travailler plus d'union avec le co vide
ces bouteilles sont plus fréquemment
utilisés et doivent être changées plus
souvent en ce qui nous concerne je
préfère que ce soit fabriqué en france
plutôt que ça soit délocalisée parce que
quand délocaliser productions telles que
c'est si médiocre il ya multiples
productions pas forcément des
productions d'ailleurs pris deux chars
et santé il ya de multiples productions
qui ont été délocalisés et bien en
période de crise on n'est pas sûr
d'avoir la garantie d'approvisionnement
c'est ça qui est important
mais andré chassaigne pense qu'il faut
réquisitionner ou nationalisé le site de
l'osce faire pour relancer la production
une proposition conforme à la tradition
communiste renforcé dans sa conviction
par les propos du président de la
république qui veut encourager
l'autonomie de notre pays sur le
matériel médical et plaide pour une
sorte de souveraineté sanitaires pour le
député la crise du comique 19 nous donne
l'occasion d'agir
le 23 mars il ya une loi qui a été votée
la loi d'urgence et dans cette loi
d'urgence
il ya un article qui permet de
réquisitionner d'entreprise kobus faire
dans la mesure où cette entreprise et
d'intérêts majeurs d'un cadre de la
crise sanitaire du coc vide 19
donc à partir de là j'ai ensuite
interrogé bruno le maire lors d'une eau
d'une visioconférence que les présidents
de groupes ont régulièrement avec le
premier ministre et son gouvernement
et là il m'a répondu qu'il n'y aurait
pas nationalisation en disant qu' il n'y
avait pas péril à 1 demeure en quelque
sorte qu'il y avait des stocks
eric il y avait aucune raison de
nationaliser une autre députée de la
région pense qu'il ne faut pas forcément
mettre l'entreprise sous la coupe de
l'état
et c'est précisément la députée de la
circonscription se trouve justement
l'ancienne usine luxair
bonjour je suis valérie thomas député de
la première circonscription du puy de
dôme clermont ferrand étant la ville
principale de cette circonscription
je suis membre de la commission des
affaires étrangères très très intéressé
par les questions de santé mondiale
sujet malheureusement brûlant
d'actualité
la députée en marche plaide elle aussi
pour une autonomie sanitaires
mais selon elle il ne faut pas se
précipiter et bien étudié sur quel
matériel la france doit concentrer ses
efforts car les pandémies de demain ne
serait pas forcément celle d'aujourd'hui
là on se retrouve face à une pandémie
qui touche qui attaque de façon très
violente le système respiratoire mais
que ce serait dommage de ne raisonner
pour l'avenir que sur le vide parce
qu'il peut y avoir d'autres pendu avec
l'arrivée du moustique tigre en france
qui s'implante de plus en plus on a des
épidémies de dengue ou de zik à la
réponse sincère ce n'est pas la même que
celle du que vide donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait une réflexion stratégique
beaucoup plus profonde
valérie thomas propose de faire un état
des lieux général des besoins en matière
sanitaire après la crise pour elle pas
sûr que l' usine luxfer s'avère être une
priorité
le problème c'est que désormais seules
trois usines au monde produisent des
bouteilles d'oxygène une en chine une en
turquie et une en angleterre
plus aucun site n'existe en europe
autant dire que pour une troisième
député de la région
oui il y as péril en la demeure bonjour
christine pierre est bonne je suis
député de la deuxième circonscription du
puy de dôme et je suis de très près le
dossier luxfer depuis fin 2010 8 c'est à
dire depuis depuis qu'on a annoncé la
fermeture de ce site à gerzat et c'est
donc pour moi en tout cas un site
stratégique qui devrait attirer je pense
l'attention de tous de tous les
décideurs publics
christine pires bonne pense qu'il faut
tirer les enseignements de la crise
actuelle dans sa circonscription qui
jouxte le site de luxe faire elle
travaille avec les professionnels de
santé pour imaginer les solutions de
demain venez de belfort là cette
ambulance il n'a pour l'instant pas de
pénurie de bouteilles
dès qu'il ya urgence et toutes vos
ambulances sont forcément une taille
minimum - de beinheim
mais avec les masques il a mesuré ce que
signifiait une pénurie de matériel ça a
été une grosse catastrophe la sueur sur
derniers mois ça a été une catastrophe
informatique les masques les protections
ça intègre les blues les gants les
lunettes les charlottes des
surchaussures et en 2020 il importe
c'est d'être en pénurie de sable
arrivé en rupture de stock sur le gène
on savait en fabriquer certains savent
et en fabriquer et de pharmacien vous
disais oui mais maintenant le problème
c'est que j'ai pas les flacons contenant
non le père de toute la chaîne de
fabrication canton quand le président de
la république et la raison dit il faut
assurer
l'indépendance sanitaires il va falloir
réfléchir à toute la chaîne
d'autant que la médecine de demain
nécessitera le développement des
bouteilles d'oxygène ultra légères comme
on l'est produisait chez l'ex faire et
quand même une volonté en france et
c'est très bien de vouloir développer
l'ambulatoire parce que l'ambulatoire
coûte beaucoup moins cher qu'un que
qu'une nuit d'hospitalisation à
l'hôpital où on n'est pas fou sauf que
pour développer l'ambulatoire il faut
avoir un truc léger vous pouvez pas on
voit souvent les malais naviguer à
l'hôpital avec soin une perf
on va aller voir de plus en plus
effectivement dans tout ce qui est pro
détresse respiratoire déambuler avec de
l'oxygène et ça ça ne peut qu'être
un alliage léger christine pires boon a
déposé une proposition de loi pour
nationaliser luxe faire mais pour elle
cette nationalisation n'est qu'une
première étape qui déboucherait ensuite
sur des prises de participations
publiques privées dont l'entreprise
pour moi la seule solution au jour
d'aujourd'hui contenu que les anglais ne
veulent pas vendre l'outil est
d'ailleurs ils ont recapitalisé pour
éviter la faillite justement là bas ça
passe ça passe malheureusement par par
la nationalisation
ce qui n'empêche pas plus ou moins long
terme de cliquer beaucoup de personnes
dedans
oui oui bien sûr on pourrait on pourrait
aussi imaginer que y compris y compris
les collectivités locales du coin que ce
soit la métropole de clermont que ce
soit la région l'europe les envies
l'écran entreprises pourquoi ne le voit
pas les français eux-mêmes et envie de
participer à cette entreprise justement
parce qu'elle est vitale pour le moment
le gouvernement semble hésiter sur le
cas l'udc ce faire mais d'autres
entreprises pourraient être concernés la
crise actuelle sera peut être l'occasion
de repenser la place de la france dans
la mondialisation
[Musique]